all right I hate that I have to do this
today
but there's been a sort of personal
thing that relates to the show going on
the last 24 hours that I want to tell
you about because it is once again just
this is the worst type of stuff that I
have to deal with as host of this show
now I'm I and the David Pakman show are
now under attack by a so-called
left-wing activists really sort of a
centrist Democratic activists and this
came up out of nowhere yesterday with no
warning and quite frankly I I need
everybody's support here so let me tell
you the story from the beginning indulge
me just for a few minutes and everybody
will be caught up back in December of
2018 a woman named Amy Siskind tweeted
on her Twitter account quote I will not
support white male candidates in the
Democratic primary unless you slept
through midterms women were our most
successful candidate biggest dem vote
getters in history Obama Oh eight
Hillary sixteen white male is not where
our party is at and is our least safe
option in 2020 now of course the biggest
dem vote getters piece ignores that when
the population grows over time you would
expect candidates to get more and more
raw votes but forget about the math
issue to me the idea that was tweeted
here is the opposite of progressive she
is saying that on the basis of race and
gender
she's ruling out supporting certain
candidates white male candidates that's
terrible
I don't agree with that now a side note
amy Siskin was a big Hillary supporter
in 2016 that's sort of her placement
within the Democratic Party and the left
and and that's fine she's part of the
Hillary wing of the party which show
she's perfectly well allowed to do and
that has nothing to do with the
criticism that I responded with so at
the time I replied
isn't there something not progressive
about preemptively dismissing a
candidate based on their race and gender
I feel like there's a word to describe
that as a progressive I won't be jumping
on board with that idea and at the time
remember this is 2018 Amy
Siskin responded to me quote secure men
are always at the forefront of diversity
they don't see their place or status
threatened by lifting women people of
color or people of all sexual
orientations because they are
comfortable with themselves suggesting
I'm neither secure and/or comfortable
with myself or uncomfortable you know
lifting women or people of color and I
responded once again that's exactly
right and I'm 100% on board with that it
seems to be the exact opposite of
preemptively disqualifying candidates on
the basis of race or gender
now tons of people saw this exchange and
started retweeting it and by the next
morning Amy Siskin had blocked me on
Twitter the next day I tweeted about
this saying the intolerant left is small
but horrible Amy siskins said she
wouldn't vote for anyone white or male
in 2020 I pointed out this is the
definition of racism and sexism I
respectfully questioned her approach she
blocked me this sent her into an
absolute rage and in addition to having
blocked me on Twitter she sought me out
on Facebook at the time she found me on
Facebook and left me the following
message on my personal Facebook account
where she said quote remember I was
teaching as an adjunct at Boston College
shortly before this she says I called
Boston College to launch a complaint
that you should not be teaching young
minds but they said you do not teach
there I reported you anyway because you
should not be invited back may want to
update your Facebook page to reflect
reality now of course I taught at BC in
2017 Facebook reflected that as an
adjunct I'm not permanently employed BC
so if you call them during the semester
where I'm not teaching they would say he
doesn't work here right now and so she
was right right these are her words she
said she called BC and told them that I
should not be teaching there this became
quite a story Joe Rogan and Bill burr
talked about this exchange that I had
with ami Siskind on Joe Rogan's program
I later went on to a Rogen's program in
June of 2019 and Joe and I spoke about
it and we put ami siskins tweet that we
Joe's producer put ami siskins tweet up
on the screen
and then I never heard anything about it
again okay that was June of 2019 it's
been seven months until yesterday
completely out of nowhere ami Siskind
appears on the David Pakman show
Facebook page and posts quote you're a
liar David I never tried to get you
fired I pointed out your LinkedIn page
didn't even include an adjunct position
and you were embellishing you owe me an
apology
you completely made it up to get
attention now as you can see this is
factually wrong notice in her post in
December she says it's my facebook
profile that misstated my position at
Boston College in her post yesterday she
says she was pointing something out from
LinkedIn so clearly she doesn't remember
the post I don't know which is accurate
was it because of Facebook or because of
LinkedIn but then she went on to post to
our Facebook page yesterday again out of
nowhere we haven't heard from her for
six seven months she says quote someone
sent me a link to an entire segment you
did with that openly racist transphobic
misogynist Joe Rogan in which you
trashed me for something made up I never
called Boston College I never tried to
get you fired this is a complete
fabrication you made up to get attention
you must publicly apologize for this
lyin smear now let me remind you Amy
herself posted on my Facebook page quote
I called Boston College to launch a
complaint that you should not be
teaching young minds but they said you
do not teach there I reported you anyway
because you should not be invited back
and this is where it's getting ugly she
is now making threats saying yesterday I
will give you today to apologize then I
will be sharing what you did publicly
now of course I did nothing wrong so I'm
not going to apologize but people who
know Amy Siskind have been warning me
she will go after your advertisers she
will go after the stations that
broadcast your show she will lobby free
speech TV to drop the David Pakman show
and she has resources behind her those
sort of centrist establishment
Democratic Party Reese
sources now anybody who looks at the
facts says seize in December of 2018 she
said I called Boston College and told
them not to have you teach there she
might have been lying back then or she's
lying now right we don't know I reached
out to Joe Rogan about this since it
relates to the conversation we had on
his show he's aware of it I've been in
touch with our legal team we just don't
know what to expect right now and it's a
really tough situation
because she does have friends in
important places in the Democratic
establishment she has the type of
support that we might call moneyed
legacy Democratic resources so I am
telling you this not so that you go out
and send Amy Siskind tweets or attacker
in fact let me be clear do not do that
that is not what I am asking anybody to
do that's not going to help us what I am
Telling You is we may be up against
something big here that could really be
damaging to the show and it'll become a
distraction from the 2020 election
coverage it'll become a distraction from
covering issues a distraction from the
coverage of the impeachment of the
President of the United States I don't
know whether this is going to end up
costing big money I don't know whether
this is going to end up losing us some
of our broadcast platforms
she has connections in the establishment
legal community the establishment
political community the establishment
media community people who could make my
life a living hell and demanding an
apology when an ultimatum does not bode
particularly well so I'm letting you
know what's going on please consider
supporting us directly
grab a membership at join pakman.com she
can Lobby our stations to drop the show
she can't do anything about people who
say I'm gonna support David Pakman
directly grab a membership at join
pakman.com use patreon patreon.com slash
david pakman show we do not want to be
bullied but we need to recognize that
she could bring some significant sort of
bully pulpit power against us it's
horrible
I this has been really stressful over
the last 24 hours
I will keep you posted that's the full
story as I know it for now one of our
sponsors is privacy calm they're giving
you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy dot-com slash Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a lifesaver and
here's how it works takes just a couple
of minutes to set up anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman